- Objectives of industry analysis.
There are at least four main objectives
of industry analysis.
To understand how industry
structure drives competition,
which in turn determines the level
of industry profitability.
To assess industry attractiveness,
meaning potential long-term profitability.
To anticipate how changes
in industry structure
may impact future profitability.
Here, strategists need to be
able to forecast and predict
future levels of profitability.
To formulate strategies that can change
the structure of an
industry, and in doing so,
improve industry profitability.
Examine this table.
It presents the median profitability
of a select number of US industries.
It reports the median return on equity
for industries from 2000 to 2010.
As you can see from the table,
different industries have very different
characteristic levels of profitability.
While the tobacco industry
had a return on equity
of 35% over that 10 year period,
the airline industry
had a minus 11.3 return.
Makes you wonder why
anyone would want to own
or operate an airline.
Immediately, you all will,
correctly, jump to the conclusion
that much of the reason for
this is the impact of 9/11
on the airline industry.
But, compare food services,
which has a return,
on average, of 19.9%.
With food production, which earns 5.2%.
Obviously, we would all prefer to compete
in the food services industry.
What explains these differences?
Is there a way to systematically
analyze the key drivers
that impact profitability
levels in industries?
Industry analysis is a subject
that consumes immense amounts
of the time of business executives,
consultants, and advisors.
Different diagnostic
frameworks and approaches
have been proposed over
the years; however,
perhaps the best and most
widely known and used
analytical framework
for analyzing industries
was developed by Michael Porter in 1979.
Michael Porter wrote and published
one of the seminal books in strategy
called Competitive Strategy in 1980.
It is still worth reading today.
Michael Porter's important contribution
to the field of strategy
was what is now called
Porter's Five Forces.
Porter simplified the
diagnosis of industry structure
into five key forces.
In a very real way, he
practiced good strategy.
He provided a simpler model
of a more complex world.
Something that managers
could actually get their heads around.
Many have come to criticize
Porter's Five Forces framework
as being overly simplistic; however,
they fail to understand
that Porter recognized
it was not possible to think
about all the things going on
in an industry at any time,
that is, the complexity of an industry,
without a simpler model.
Porter understood that there
were three key influences,
or determinants, of
industry profitability.
The first, the value of the
product to the customer.
That is their willingness to pay.
Second, intensity of industry rivalry.
And third, the relative bargaining power
of different players at different stages
of the industry value chain.
Porter created a framework
that simplified the drivers
of competitive intensity
and attractiveness of
markets into five forces.
Number one, bargaining power of suppliers.
Number two, bargaining power of buyers.
Number three, rivalry among existing firms
within the industry.
Number four, the threat of new
entrants into the industry.
And number five, threat of substitute.
Let's discuss each of these
in a little bit more detail.